Living Planet Index has come out with an
interesting study and it says that
animal populations have halved in 40
years which is completely insane we've
got some info for you the report says
that humans are cutting down trees more
quickly than they can regrow harvesting
more fish than the oceans can restock
pumping water from rivers and aquifers
faster than rainfall can replenish them
and emitting more carbon than oceans and
forests can absorb we've got a little
more foria populations of mammals birds
reptiles amphibians and fish have
declined by an average of 52 percent
over the course of the last 40 years
populations of freshwater species have
suffered and even worse while at 76% in
Ghana the lion population in one reserve
is down 90 percent in 40 years
globally habitat loss and hunting have
reduced Tigers from a hundred thousand a
century ago to just three thousand so I
don't want to get totally caught up in
all the numbers of that and I'm sure
someone else is gonna come out with a
study saying that's not true and that
the Lions in Ghana had some weird
disease or some other thing like that
but there's obviously some sort of trend
here and this weekend because I can
relate anything back to a
science-fiction movie I watched avatar
and this is pretty much what it's about
like eventually we are just gonna rape
this earth of everything it's God and
we're gonna ruin the water and we're
gonna pollute the air and we're gonna
kill the animals and we're doing it
already
and that's why Japan is literally right
now building a staircase to space did
you know about that by 2050 they're
building this elevator and that's what
this all made me think so that's sort of
where I want to take this conversation
are we just wrecking for getting the
specifics of this study like are we just
and we're doing it we're knowing we're
knowingly doing it right now right we
absolutely aren't yet forgetting the
specifics because it's really difficult
to say that you know we've had the
population of something when it when we
can't even really account for the vast
number of species right so it's that's
really really difficult to do but it is
troubling to hear that we are
eliminating so many species and that we
don't think to really care I think
that's where the issue is like we're
starting to care more and more about
like global warming but
at least I don't hear it very often or
you don't see it very often in the media
they're like oh this species just when
it's extinct it happens all the time
that it's no longer sort of interesting
to hear that this or this happened
yeah we just excelling Darwin's theory
basically like it's evolution kind of
like and we're at the top so we're just
making everything go faster for those
poor guys on the bottom organisms that
have improved Fitness organisms that
thrive versus organisms that die off if
we're actually talking about true
Darwinian evolution natural selection is
an organism that thrives is one that can
adapt to a changing environment but
historically the environment didn't
change nearly as rapidly as we're
forcing it to change which means that
the mechanisms at play the the way that
an organism would have a mutation and
then breed and then eventually take over
its population it can't keep up
so it's nobody has an option to thrive
nobody has an option to survive which is
why species are dying left and right and
it is incredibly depressing
there's a famous kind of cartoon that
you can google and I feel really bad
that I don't know the name of the artist
so so google it and well fine okay great
and it's called the fence and it shows
you know in the first frame a really
lush green earth and this is you know
two hundred thousand years ago we didn't
have agriculture we didn't have we were
hunter-gatherers and we were living with
nature and then it shows all these
different iterations until we finally
get to this really brown earth with a
tiny little fence and in between it says
things like we call it a fence it
protects our livestock from wild animals
and you have all these small areas that
are fenced in and eventually it
completely flips to where we call it a
fence it protects the wildlife from us
it makes a nature preserve and that's
really where we are now
wildlife is fenced in whereas we used to
fence ourselves in from the wild the
wild isn't even the wild now we are the
major apex predators and we have as you
said before I think it's an appropriate
term albeit one that's maybe a little
insensitive
we have raped the planet of its
resources yeah I don't even see it as
insensitive because that to me is what
we're defining it can't defend itself it
does bounce back sometimes and
another is that Jurassic Park you know
life will find a way so nature nature
dance my toe will not destroy Planet
Earth
we will make Planet Earth in habitable
for humans and we will die off and
nature will find a way to subsist we'll
take a lot of species with us but then
they will be able to rebuild and
repopulate our earth then we want to
thinking yeah my cockroaches will be
climbing over and jellyfish taken over
be going up that that elevator in Japan
um does it matter if certain species
disappear like the dodo bird you know
like that's the famous one that the dodo
bird disappeared but me you know partly
like it's like there's an emotional
piece like oh I wish that species still
existed but maybe it doesn't matter if
something like maybe some of these
things are supposed to have an
expiration date I'm doing a little
devil's advocate here but yeah you know
I think we're all interconnected though
like you can say that okay the dodo
species maybe it wasn't that important
but it's really hard to determine what
type of impact that particular species
had on the environment perhaps we didn't
eat the dodo bird I'm not even sure
people did that but you know it could
have been a keystone species like there
are very different functions that
animals play and it disrupts the
ecosystem when you take one player out
and we don't know how the ecosystem will
change and will shift in response to
that and that's where I think it gets
dangerous and I think the point that you
just made when you take one player out
is a good point we physically take these
players out if they were falling out
because of natural pressures that would
be different we are killing them off
because of our behavior and I think that
that's a totally different kind of
judgment right and right now we're
having all these studies about how bee
populations are dying and bees we need
to pollinate things other things can
grow a net and it's just sharks like
massive apex predators in the ocean
large fish we're overfishing sharks
which is horrible but we're also
overfishing swordfish and tuna like the
the ocean is being absolutely depleted
not just from overfishing but because of
the massive amounts the ocean is a
carbon sink and it's having to take in
too much carbon and it's becoming acidic
because of that yeah alright so last
thought on this is the biggest problem
with this is that it all happens so
slowly and over the course of so many
years and decades that you know there's
never like suddenly an instant that
wakes everybody up
because there's just this slowed
aggregation of what's going on here
so nobody ever wakes up - especially
because we don't see it as you know
Kerry mentioned we have the wildlife
fenced in right and we're completely
removed from them you know we see our
food and wildlife and nuggets all the
time on our plate and we there's no gets
into the trade I know I think the to
your point it happened so slowly yes but
it depends on your scale because it's
actually happening significantly faster
than nature would have ever allowed
before these things should be happening
on the scale of hundreds of thousands to
millions of years and it's happening on
the scale of decades now so even though
it's slow for our human eyes it's
definitely not slow in the grand scheme
of things